i watched the
addison ray remake that he's all that
and then i and then i watched she's all
that afterward did you really i watched
the whole thing afterwards just to be
like okay
let me make sure i'm not foolish i
looked at the budget okay for it was 200
so the budget for he's all that which
was the netflix remake with addison was
20 million what yeah 20 million and 19
million went to edison yeah
i was gonna say like my favorite or
sorry my least favorite genre of content
right now
is
low budget netflix
rom-com teen movies like kissing booth
all those bro [ __ ] stupid ass movies
with noah whatever in them and i thought
this was one of them no i literally i
saw the trailer for this and i was like
250 bucks must be the budget for this
yeah it's shot like half of it is shot
like 60
frames per second which
for anyone who's not a film nerd it
looks like real time like it doesn't
feel like film why call it he's all that
why not just call it the addison ray
movie
in parentheses this kind of leans into
she's all that there's a moment where
addison ray goes through mail and the
male looks like
male someone brought from their house
okay because they forgot to get mail for
the scene all like the framing and
everything it's like how
uh a 16 year old would shoot a movie
none of the shots feel cohesive or
whatever it's just like they're just
grabbing parts what kind of like kicks
off the drama is addison ray
gets angry at her boyfriend because she
walks in on him cheating on her and
she's live streaming while live
streaming she's crying because she's so
upset and everyone makes fun of her
because she has snot coming out of her
nose
and they're all referring to her as
bubble girl so she loses tons of tons of
followers because you know that's what
he's all that is about is your social
media empire [ __ ] yeah and then you know
on more we need more movies about social
media yeah and on time guess who calls
her her main brand sponsor
kourtney kardashian okay aka someone
who's is basically kourtney kardashian
and she just dogs out addison for having
[ __ ] snot bubbles in her nose and
hangs on
in every single one of these movies it's
always like so cookie cutter like 90s
style high school where people are
calling other people bubble girl it's
like that's not what it is no
these kids are vaping tell them telling
that like each other to go kill
themselves on tick-tock so that's what
bullying is right so that's where i say
she's all that got it right first of all
the first minute of she's all that
probably like a 200 scene okay yeah the
dialogue and [ __ ] is really corny like
it there's a lot of cheesy [ __ ] in there
but there's also like shades of art that
make it kind of endearing but
in the first like six or seven minutes
of the movie when they're establishing
all the characters the main like girl
who's like supposed to be a loser or
whatever she's in art class and her
teacher's like hey you know like i want
to see more from you and these two girls
walk up to her and the most like
you know these gothic looking chicks and
they're like
hey
you know we've been looking at your art
and
we just we notice how dark it is one of
the girls goes
yeah dark is dark rules and then they
start going on about our art and they're
like we were also thinking how like
great artists don't get recognized and
you know
unless it's like a posthumous way you
know it's like until they're gone like
picasso
like basquiat they're like yeah
so we were thinking maybe better
if you just killed yourself
that's in the first eight minutes of the
movie eight or nine minutes yeah yeah
see that's that's really it hasn't
changed yeah but somehow these networks
think that they shouldn't show the real
version of high school yeah that's the
other part is there's so many obvious
brand moments in the remake i'm like
this budget is already so dog [ __ ] yeah
you needed brand money too yeah come on
man how was addison ray's acting
bad was it bad in the sense that i don't
know if it was necessarily her fault
right it could have been directing her
that way right it's a ballsy ass thing
to to take this role because
like the amount of traffic netflix
drives is
unbelievable just look at too ought to
handle any of these shows yeah people
just instantly become stars afterwards
because millions of people are on the
netflix homepage every single day
looking for new [ __ ] to watch right they
knew this was going to be front center
top of the most trending and she took
the lead and as far as i know she's
never had acting experience before maybe
she has i don't know but still it's
ballsy as [ __ ] to take that it's just
and just you know you're gonna get
slammed i feel bad for her in the sense
that she's young and it's probably her
stupid-ass parents that are like you
should definitely do it and her dumbass
agent was like definitely you need to do
this i mean i don't think
yeah it was i don't think it's a bad
idea though even if she like crashes and
burns and gets made fun of for this it's
like
still just like getting in front like
getting on a platform like this yeah in
front of people she can act like immune
and all that but is she yeah could like
will she watch this back and like be
like
[ __ ] i want to blow my brains out you
know what i mean yeah like that's the
part i think that's not fair yeah i see
like she's still a kind of a kid if you
were 22 and you got a lead role like
that and the whole of the internet is
like dude
you're [ __ ] useless
damn yeah rough script for anyone to
chew on you could even see like the more
straight up actors like the people who
aren't necessarily influencers [ __ ]
struggling with that dialogue
really trying to like
like all right i'm trying to give it
some sort of natural yeah they're like
trying to capture the essence and then
so many inner cuts of like people not
naked why don't you scram bubble girl
yeah yeah yeah yeah bubble girl just
doesn't work
can i call her something else no you
have to call her bubble girl what about
it's like snot knows like something a
little bit oh bubble girl it's hashtag
bubblegum actually hold on getting a
note from the
copy producers are requesting you say
hashtag bubblegirl why don't you scram
with your beats pill
hashtag bubble girl that's the line
addison when she says why don't you
scram hashtag bubblegirl make sure you
hold up the beats pill to your face
before you cry yeah okay
action scram bubble girl
can't live fine your girls were
undeniable teenage ting bikinis on top
the massive presence of a tick-tocker
no money spent on music
or score yeah it is literally all like
stock like youtube [ __ ] oh yeah that's
yeah i noticed that too about these
movies every time you watch one of these
it's epidemic sound feels like a youtube
video yeah yeah that's what like the the
[ __ ] opens up and i'm
you know typically i feel that films
either open on like some
really intense scene like in silence
that like sets the tone or it's gonna
open on some kind of some kind of like
score or soundtrack that's like damn
yeah
like she's all that it's like grunge
music for the first minute and it's like
the girl's painting and you just get the
vibe you're like okay yeah in this movie
it's eeny
in it audio jungle
i love waking up and eating my
mcdonald's cheeseburger before starting
my day
there's a laugh track too yeah
she takes a bite out of that oh my god
let me check my samsung smartphone for
all my text messages that i've received
through wechat my samsung foldable
smartphone galaxy s5 click
i love the way it folds easy to put in
my pocket the biggest [ __ ] violation
that they make in the first five minutes
is on-screen graphics
she like begins a live stream
and instead of spending a hundred
[ __ ] dollars
to get the shot through an actual phone
and like get some cheap vfx on it to
make it feel like it was through a phone
they just put it right on the frame yes
i love that you know and the graphics
are a little bit wrong and crisp and
clean yeah and just like
yeah it's
a school camera oh dude
what is happening hey i'm streaming from
my re yeah yeah dawg
so annoying i want to make a short film
where it's all viners and every every
bit of dialogue as a brand injection
yeah yeah yeah right and i was saying i
wanted it to be an action movie and it's
like all call outs it's like oh [ __ ]
he's getting away in the brand new 2021
audi s6
i think that's that's fine because the
other mercedes-benz c300
with ecoboost some people don't even
have dialogue they just announce what
they are yeah i'm the poor person and it
cuts to a completely different scene
[Laughter]
or like super long contextual statements
yeah like addison i know your mom died
when you were four and you felt really
sad about it up until now because you
got a date with corey and it made you
feel a little bit better about it and
you have some deep-rooted issues because
your mom's still dying and you haven't
really gotten over it but i think you
should go talk to him
yeah i would but
you're just kind of being hard on me
ever since your dad broke his two
kneecaps in that skiing accident and
completely changed your outlook on life
causing you to be a bit less reserved
and a bit more forward thinking i'm just
not in that same place because remember
my mom died in that car accident when i
was four and i just haven't really
recovered from that
well here
here's a beats pill to make you feel
better about that oh my god i love this
brand new addison oops i love this new
song by badison ray
and then the teacher comes up
whoa is this that new baddest and ray
song available on tim tam
tim tan but for some people tick tock